bonsoir nous sommes le lundi 2 mai merci
de nous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 le journal comme chaque
jour nous revenons sur votre actualité
locale entouré de nous inviter mais
également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite on commence avec
les titres de cette édition
ludovic kaufmann nouveau directeur
départemental de la sécurité publique
des yvelines il a été intronisé ce matin
devant les services de police et succède
à jean-marie salanova qui avait quitté
ses fonctions le 8 avril dernier chien
life for humanity un festival en mémoire
des victimes du terrorisme il est
organisé par l'association jamais jeunes
actifs pour la mémoire association
internationale du souvenir un événement
en préparation qui devrait avoir lieu en
novembre prochain à saint quentin en
yvelines dans le vélodrome nationale
pour nous en parler ce soir en plateau
florian beaufils président de
l'association et enfin 1er mai
ensoleillé dimanche pour le plus grand
bonheur de tous avec la tradition du
muguet offert pour porter chance
pourtant cette année il s'est fait rare
et certains ont eu bien du mal à en
trouver
et pour commencer cette information
samedi 30 mai au matin samedi 30 avril
pardon matin le président de la
république s'est rendu à jouy en josas
en toute confidentialité l'événement
n'était pas annoncée sur l'agenda du
président de la république qui est allé
se recueillir sur la tombe de léon blum
enterrés dans le cimetière de la ville
accompagnée de la mer il a également
visité la maison dans laquelle a vécu et
est décédé le 30 mars 1950 le leader du
front populaire et je vous le disais en
titre ce matin les services de police
appuyée le nouveau directeur
départemental de la sécurité publique
des yvelines
ludovic kaufmann succède donc à
jean-marie sala nova qui avait quitté
ses fonctions le 8 avril dernier une
cérémonie d'installation a eu lieu ce
matin en préfecture de versailles
williams elle était sur place regarder
nouvellement
par contre hétéroclite qu'affiche le
nouveau directeur départemental de la
sécurité publique des yvelines après
avoir passé une grande partie de sa
carrière dans le val de marne
principalement dans la sécurité publique
ludovic kaufmann appris ce matin ses
nouvelles fonctions dans le département
j'ai fait quasiment tous les métiers qui
peuvent existence sécurité publique que
ce soit en terme de gestion que ce soit
en termes de police judiciaire puisque
j'ai été plus de 80 demi adjoint dans
une sûreté départementale
j'étais chef d'état-major j'étais
directeur adjoint tout cela dans le val
de marne en règle générale ludovic
hoffman succède ainsi à jean marie
salanova qui a quitté ses fonctions de 8
avril dernier avec l'objectif de
poursuivre et développer les mesures
déjà engagées par son prédécesseur
de toute manière les priorités sont de
trois niveaux la première comme je
voulais 10 et le décompte la délinquance
avec des priorités ni menthe est définie
par le ministre de l'intérieur
la deuxième priorité ça va être de
maintenir l'ordre public qui fait partie
des missions régaliennes de l'état
la troisième priorité c'est défendre les
valeurs de la république
aussi je tiens à ce qu'on ait une police
exemplaire lutte contre le cambriolage
ou vol avec violence des policiers qui
continueront à être sur tous les fronts
comme sur les routes avec les beaux
jours qui arrivent
les accidents nombreux avec les deux
roues notamment qui resteront une
priorité je pense en tout cas ce soir
l'une des miennes
les contrôles routiers vont être
accentués sur ce département des
policiers déjà largement sollicité
depuis les attentats et desquels ludovic
hoffman exigera une exemplarité total en
affirmant qu'il restera toujours leur
premier soutien et la villa de
coignières se met au digital la commune
lance son application mobile officiel et
débarque sur votre smartphone
téléchargeable gratuitement sur les
plateformes apple et android elle permet
de rester connecté d'être informé en
temps réel de suivre l'actualité de la
ville en retrouvant toutes les
informations pratiques mais aussi de
recevoir les alertes instantanées de la
mairie toutes les informations sont
disponibles sur les sites internet de
coignières et nous accueillons à présent
ce soir au plateau florian beaufils
bonsoir bonsoir merci à d'avoir accès à
notre invitation alors vous êtes là le
président de l'association jamais jeunes
actifs pour la mémoire association
internationale du souvenir
donc c'est une association de devoir de
mémoire qui organise également des
concerts et des spectacles caritatif
votre association possède donc une
antenne à saint quentin en yvelines
depuis 2013 elle existe depuis 2013 elle
existe depuis 2010 tel son objectif est
ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un peu
plus alors en quelques mots notre
objectif ce n'est objectifs sont assez
simple au départ en été on a créé cette
association pour faire du devoir de
mémoire auprès des jeunes fait par les
jeunes donc vous voyez passer un message
intergénérationnel bon oui j'en ai 26 le
plus jeune a 15
le but c'était intéressé donc des gens
de notre âge à le passer
constatant qu'on avait un peu de mal à
intéresser donc les gens à venir aux
commémorations on s'est posé quelques
questions disant qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire de plus pour intéresser
les gens les ados les jeunes adultes et
on s'est dit tiens si on faisait un
petit peu de culture en faisant en
organisant des concerts et des
spectacles et de fil en aiguille on a un
gros si on a grossi et en maintenant on
est un peu partout en france
vous êtes voilà donc 140 membres tout à
fait comment définiriez vous voilà ce
que votre association le devoir de
mémoire pour ceux qui ne savent pas
vraiment ce que c'est alors devoir de
mémoire ses intérêts c'est donc à nous
passer des gens qui sont battu pour
notre liberté pour notre pays un son est
vraiment nationalistes on est bon il
faut pas faire d'amalgamé c'est très
important
puis voilà parce que j'aime bien prendre
cet exemple là en quarts en 1940 45 et
les actes de résistance sont des gens
qui sont battu pour notre liberté pour
le nazisme qu'est ce que c'était c'était
la lutte
c'était la haine de l'autre le racisme
antisémitisme et ces gens ont pris le
fusil pour lutter contre contre tout
cela est donc âge
aujourd'hui c'est un peu à notre tour de
dire voilà bon c'est bien messieurs
messieurs dames si avec ces demoiselles
qui ont pris les armes
c'est un peu notre tour maintenant de
prendre la relève et de continuer votre
votre combat pour justement pas que ça
soit pas oublier que vous serez cris
fils ne soit pas oublié
alors appelez donc l'histoire le passé
de la france pour cela donc vous me
dites heures vous organisez beaucoup
d'événements notamment musicaux celui
adopté au vélodrome qui va certainement
avoir lieu le 11 et 12 novembre on y
reviendra dans quelques instants
et vous avez fait d'autres événements
auparavant à ce que nous en dira un peu
plus alors pour le devoir de mémoire oui
on a fait quelques beaux événements on a
fait de war3 le plus beau ça a été le
défilé d'oyonnax donc à oyonnax pour le
110e anniversaire
défilé c'était donc le nez maquisards
qui ont défilé sous le nez néo nazi
s'était il faut avoir de l'audace et du
courage et donc on a eu la joie de
recevoir le président de la république
pour cet événement on a fait aussi un
mémoire de a toujours dans l'ain a
à côté d'ambérieu-en-bugey à côté de
lyon on affine est donc une
réconciliation historique on a fait
venir des conférenciers pour le concert
des gros événements et sur les concerts
on a fait on a créé deux festivals un
qui s'appelle soit il arrive donc ce
n'est pas vraiment un concert c'est un
festival d'humour
on a notre cinquième édition au mois de
mai et on a créé aussi un festival qui
s'appelle super bowl pour donc pour
aider les plus démunis
alors justement à vous préparez donc un
autre événement qui aura lieu à saint
quentin en yvelines donc au vélodrome le
11 et le 12 novembre prochain qui
s'appelle play for humanity ont pour
rendre hommage aux victimes du
terrorisme pourquoi cette initiative
c'est peut-être changer un petit peu
mais celle que vous avez habituellement
alors notre association fait toujours
des concerts caritatifs ça c'est l'un de
nos objectifs d'aider l'association qui
se déjà qu'ils évitent tout comme j'ai
dis donc coopératives et autres et donc
nous avons été bien sûr comme beaucoup
de la population française choqué par ce
qui s'est passé et on veut rendre
hommage à notre manière à ces gens ça
peut être moi vous on a l'âge d'aller au
bataclan d'aller voir des concerts
d'aller sortir et autres donc on a voulu
dire voilà on est jeune on a voulu le
toucher notre génération
maintenant on va regarder on va se
battre en faisant un concert et en plus
en étant solidaire donc c'est vraiment
le jeu de base
voilà c'est un événement d'une
importance à ces voix lasse assez grand
en avait assez important c'est un
événement participatif collaboratif
comment ça va se passer comment c'est un
petit peu organisés vous faites appel
aux dons justement pour cet événement
tout à fait donc j'ai créé une cagnotte
sur litchi bontempelli fort dynamique là
vous voyez donc justement le hockey
parfait c'est génial et donc vont nous
attendons bien sûr des dons nous avons
fait aussi des demandes auprès de
ministères la culture d'éducation
nationale auprès d'un casque hi auprès
de la région près les départements donc
nous attendons tous tout ce beau monde
est bon je crois à la force politique
j'ai confiance en eux je confiance on va
dire la société civile donc je sais que
ce projet se fera
très concrètement ça sur deux jours donc
ça est un événement comme important il y
aura des conserveurs d'inhumation des
conférences des débats commencent à se
dérober
alors concert sur deux jours ou en effet
donc variété rock avec bon je veux dire
c'était quelques artistes il y aura les
fatals picards il y aura soignera
o'shea qui a participé à cet artiste
implique également justement par rapport
au terrorisme
tout à fait mais qui ceux qui ont des
paroles vives qui sont engagés soit no 6
et le lendemain donc que nous avons mass
hysteria dagoba one is a cité d'autres
d'autres groupes
donc voilà tous ces groupes là sont
engagés ont la volonté de participer à
ce projet parce que ça ne tient vraiment
à coeur
vous êtes aidé par d'autres associations
vous avez mutualiser un peu vos forces
pour ça va tellement alors oui donc là
je suis en contact avec des associations
de la faculté des veline je suis aussi
en contact mon meilleur avec
l'association d'aidé aux victimes du
terrorisme
et puis d'autres mais que vont de suite
de mémoire je pourrais pas vous le dire
mais je pourrais le mettre sur le lien
litchi pour les personnes qui
s'intéressent vous pouvez nous contacter
sur notre site internet
c'est la première fois qu'un tel
événement de votre session est organisée
dans les yvelines tout à fait avant on
fait des petits concerts de 200 300
personnes mais là c'est vrai qu'on
attend au minimum 2000 pour faire
pouvoir faire un bon don à l'association
d'aidé aux victimes et ils ont besoin
d'argent
actuellement que voilà il plus en plus
de liaisons que vous récolterez pour à
cet événement sera reversée à également
alors les dons qu'on fait actuellement
c'est pour financer le projet et le
projet après permettra de financer donc
donné de beaucoup plus d'argent au final
aux victimes du terrorisme
donc la question financière est assez
important événement connaît même une
enceinte qui est assez important qui
peut accueillir beaucoup de gens vous
êtes autonome financièrement habitez
vous vous débrouillez alors d'habitude
c'est en s'auto finance donc son amant
au moi même qui n'ont de l'argent pour
pouvoir financer les projets
et c'est vrai que là pour ce projet là
on a un besoin d aide
donc c'est pour ça d'où cet appel
exceptionnel de notre part ce d'habitude
on s'autofinance au financement de nos
projets et quand il ya les bénéfices ont
les rawdon d'association c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui en tant que l'association de
vivre sans justement les aides de l'état
on voit notamment avec les belles
dotations a finalement il ya pas mal
d'action qui s'en sortent plus ou moins
bien alors comme on dit qu'on n'a pas
d'argent
des idées donc jusqu'à aujourd'hui on a
eu on était très très inventif et on a
pu avoir quelques beaux projets qui
coûtait pas trop trop cher parce qu'ils
aient encore le cas du vélodrome on a
bien pu réduire le coût du projet mais
bon c'est vrai que là ça gagnent pas de
plus en plus difficile mais ce qui est
de plus en plus difficile c'est que là
on voit qu'il ya quand même
suite aux attentats malheureusement de
moins en moins de monde qui se déplace
au spectacle et il faut pas que ça
continue il faut au contraire plus il ya
bien un renouveau que les gens voteront
dans l'eifel alors selon vous justement
est ce qu'il est déjà temps de faire un
travail de mémoire sur les attentats
alors que la france est encore menacée
on en parle c'est encore un sujet
d'actualité il faut déjà y réfléchir et
il pensait comme ça personnellement j'ai
un peu glissé un peu sensible là c'est
mon avis personnel que je donne je pense
qu'il faut le faire c'est important de
le faire et surtout ne pas les oublier
un ski a été on va dire où j'étais très
surpris c'est d'entendre dire de la part
de donc l'association que bon ils ont dû
gérer cette sensation d'être oublié
les familles des victimes ont à dire
cette sensation là donc c'est à nous de
leur dire non non vous n'êtes pas oublié
regardez on se bat pour vous on veut
continuer à vous soutenir à être là un
en deux endroits là l'objectif de ce
festival c'est que aussi c'est qu'on
puisse le rendre le pérenniser d'année
en année la moyenne d'âge dans la
société à ces jeunes en moyenne donc 21
ans
est ce que justement par lequel les
attentats le terrorisme c'est quelque
chose qui touche plus les jeunes est ce
que vous avez ce ressenti à vous quand
vous dites à vos membres tout à fait
comme quand je lui dis donc le bataclan
on a bien pu voir que la moyenne d'âge
c'était un peu notre notre public un
coin quand je vous dis ça peut être
ou moi ça peut être des gens qu'on
connaissait d'ailleurs on en connaissait
dans le bataclan donc forcément oui ça
nous a touchés et on a vraiment cette
volonté de fer et de passer un message
de paix de fraternité
voilà par ce biais là je vais organiser
d'autres actions
à côté des gros événements que vous avez
étudié le rôle à l'année des
reconstitutions des débats des
conférences on organise à peu près donc
on fait 1 brest une conférence par mois
et puis après en rhône-alpes eux ont
fait un événement caritatif à peu près
tous les deux mois donc voilà c'est
quelque chose qu'on essaie de
concessions débattait ce que vous
recherchez des bénévoles par exemple sur
saint quentin en yvelines
en plus on est de fous plus on rigole
voilà oui ans je me suis levé pour dire
oui ça m'arrive n'a peut-être des
ambitions de développement
oui aussi vous cherchait justement à
muscler les rencontres montrer puis
pourquoi pas être un peu parrain de la
cession des deux victimes du terrorisme
qui souhaitent organiser des conférences
moi j'ai pas dit tout à l'heure parce
que j'ai un peu survolé le sujet du
festival mais on a comme volonté aussi
d'organiser des conférences avec
l'association d'aidé aux victimes
justement avec la faculté de
de 50 ans merci beaucoup florian
beaufils life for humanity si vous
voulez plus d'informations n'hésitez pas
à vous rendre sur donc le site internet
et la cagnotte au litchi si vous
souhaitez participer en tout cas merci à
vous je le rappelle l'événement s'il a
lieu un jour c'est sûr qu'il aura lieu
ce sera le 11 et le 12 novembre au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines merci à vous
faire merci beaucoup
économie à présent aujourd'hui seulement
un tiers des chefs d'entreprise sont des
femmes à 51 ans n'est ville
l'association a créé active les aide
dans leurs démarches afin d'entreprendre
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de
l'une de ses membres
daniela elle tient une boutique de
décoration à saint quentin en yvelines à
fanny bourdillon vous dresse son
portrait entreprendre daniela connaît
bien
en 2003 elle décide de quitter son poste
d'expert comptable à auchan pour lancer
sa propre entreprise
elle se tourne alors vers la décoration
sa passion depuis toujours et créer dany
décoration à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est vraiment une envie qu'on a un
moment donné de se détacher 2
d'un travail quotidien peut un peu
routinier et c'est une ce terme par
contre de combattant quand même créer
une entreprise il faut être tenace et ne
pas ne pas perdre l'espoir et continuer
à avancer pour monter son entreprise
elle rejoint alors créactive
l'association aide les femmes depuis
2003 à concrétiser leurs projets à
l'époque elles étaient 7
aujourd'hui elles sont près d'une
cinquantaine kreactive c'est un
incubateur de savoir et de partage
et c'est des femmes extraordinaires qui
ont créé leur entreprise et ou qui sont
en cours de création et qui vient
chercher en fait à un soutien une écoute
parce que nous on sait écouter en fait
et il y en a beaucoup qui ont rentré
dans l'association qui ont réussi à
créer leur entreprise grâce aux aides
des membres donc ça c'est très important
si elle ne compte pas ses heures elle
forme volontiers des apprentis une
priorité pour cette chef d'entreprise
fur et à mesure peut-être qu'on a aussi
des futurs entrepreneurs
donc si nous en tant que femme et chef
d'entreprise on transmet pas cette envie
on leur donne pas tous les outils
comment voulez que les jeunes créent ils
peuvent pas un tiers des chefs
d'entreprise aujourd'hui sont des femmes
alors mesdames n'hésitez plus
lancez-vous objectifs du gouvernement
pouvoir atteindre les 40% d'ici 2017 et
aujourd'hui lundi nous retrouvons la
chronique culturelle de sephora namani
sephora bonsoir nous sort fait longtemps
qu'on n'a pas fait un croix n'est que
cultura la vraie celle manquée et oui
aujourd'hui vous devez vous présenter le
festival métal open sphère qui aura lieu
à saint quentin en yvelines vendredi et
samedi prochain exactement alors le
festival métal open ce faire est une
première édition organisée par
l'association vie chinoise mais à la
sauce qui oeuvre pour la promotion des
musiques amplifiées dans le département
et viennois et plus particulièrement sur
saint quentin il mène différentes
actions comme l'accompagnement de
groupes locaux et bien sûr par ailleurs
organise des concerts et festivals
alors ils ont organisé d'ailleurs deux
éditions en 2013 en 2014 d'un festival
qui s'appelait métal spm et alster
pardon et qui avait lieu en extérieur
je vous êtes très au courant vous aimez
le métal floral je ne connais pas très
bien en fait ah bon alors on va s'y
intéresser ensemble
donc cette année aura lieu la première
édition en intérieur en partenariat avec
le café de la plage de maurepas pierre
michel planchon coordinateur de metas
nous en dit plus l'idée de proposer un
événement voilà c'est marquant à durant
cette saison autour de l'esthétique
métal on voulait une programmation
plutôt éclectique dans le genre voilà
très ouverts d'où le open c'est quand
même le métal s'instille où il ya plein
de sous genres de pas mal de choses donc
on voulait que ce soit assez
représentatif de nine et d'ouverture
voilà un peu fraternité entre les
différentes choses se salit d ouverture
aux autres et diversité culturelle et
programmation éclectique vous l'avez
compris ce sont les maîtres mots
il y aura donc du métal progressif du
corps du trash de l'instrumental du
stoner du death et de l'acoustique
ça fait beaucoup donc livre à neuf
groupes différents qui vont jouer sur
deux jours le vendredi 6 mai au café de
la paix de la plage à maurepas à partir
de 20 heures ou samedi à la salle de la
tour sur voisins le bretonneux à partir
de 18 heures voilà c'est ça dont chacun
fera un passage de 45 minutes à une
heure et parmi ces groupes nous
retrouverons le groupe oracle que nous
avions d'ailleurs reçu sur le plateau du
kiosque qui propose du death progressif
ou encore le groupe drouot avec un métal
acoustique
voilà
non
ouah
alors de route le groupe que l'on vient
d'écouter d'ailleurs le groupe parrainé
cette année par l'association met ta
sauce alors parmi ces neuf groupes
qu'est ce qu'on va retrouver des groupes
locaux des invités alors principalement
des groupes locaux élite et élite et
aidants de promouvoir les groupes
yvelinois come back in time with
gazoline qui est un groupe
ramboll est un il y aura également deux
têtes d'affiché deux invités à
reconnaissance nationale comme le groupe
et green day
c'est
erin des donc groupe toulousain connu
pour sa vision avant-gardiste et
expérimentale du métal est donc la
deuxième tête d'affiché ce sera the
walking dead orchestra groupe grenoblois
cette fois ci à la reconnaissance
nationale et internationale l'un des
groupes vraiment phare de la scène du
des scores français
ce
aucun rapport avec la série the walking
dead dont le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que c'est assez énergique comme
musique voilà c'est ça énergie que c'est
vrai que le métal se caractérise par un
son lourd dé sont souvent saturées au
niveau de la guitare une rythmique
rapide pour la batterie certains parlent
même de violence dans la musique et puis
ce chiant un peu éraillée comme ça qui
est vraiment la signature rock du métal
alors on pourrait croire que le chanteur
lui hurle simplement mais bien au
contraire ça relève d'une technique de
chant très avancé comme metal par son
champ un peu voilà saturé conditions à
sabarat y maintenant c'est vraiment une
technique particulière donc c'est quand
même assez marquant d'identité c'est une
technique va de respiration en fait qui
a fait avancer on comprime l'air en fait
ne fait bouger les muqueuses de la gorge
donc c'est pas genre à gueuler dessus
c'est vraiment une technique voilà de
chant qui joue beaucoup sur la
respiration sur son contrôle de soi eh
bien merci à sephora nous avoir fait
découvrir le métal alors je le rappelle
le festival métal open sphère aura lieu
le vendredi 6 mai à partir de 20 heures
au café de la plage de maurepas et
samedi 7 mai à partir de 18h à la salle
de la tour de voisins-le-bretonneux plus
d'informations sur la fiche qui
s'adresse votre affiche des ratios votre
écran ça fera plaisir à notre lycée
camille lambert merci beaucoup
et hier dimanche 1er mai c'était la fête
du travail mais aussi le jour où il
fallait offrir du muguet chaque année
c'est près de 60 millions de brins de
muguet qui sont vendus dans toute la
france 2016 n'a pas échappé à la règle
même si la météo de ces dernières
semaines a compliqué la tâche des
vendeurs mais aussi des acheteurs
regarder la tradition ne se perd pas
bien au contraire
en ce 1er mai ils étaient nombreux à
vouloir leur fleur porte bonheur
pourtant dimanche pour avoir son brin de
muguet il fallait se lever tôt certains
ont eu de la chance je me suis dit je
vais attendre dimanche parce que c'est
le 1er mai
j'arrive en retard j'ai eu du mal à
trouver oui et d'autres moins moi sur
lyon on en trouve à des carrefours mais
là chez bizarrement j'ai pas vu
d'habitude il ya des petits jeunes
incarne l'agent n'est pas trouvée
j'aurais voulu enfin vraiment des brins
de muguet par des compositions
les fleuristes ont été pris d'assaut
comme ici à guyancourt où il ne restait
plus beaucoup de muguet en fin de
matinée les professionnels sont doutés
cette année avec la météo capricieuse du
mois d'avril
il a eu du mal à pousser les production
était réduite due au mauvais temps les
en serre et son épouse ont été très très
vert le muguet peut-être travers du coup
les fournisseurs nous ont appelés pour
nous dire que nos commandes étaient
restreintes
du coup on n'avait plus le muguet à midi
dans les rues les vendeurs de muguet à
eux aussi se faisait rare mais avec de
la persévérance on pouvait quand même
espérer souhaité du bonheur et de la
chance en ce 1er mai et on referme ce
journal avec du sport les finales de
l'open de tennis d'elancourt était
organisée ce samedi au parc des sports à
guy boniface le tournoi fêter cette
année sa 28e édition plus de 350
sportifs se sont inscrits pour cette
compétition regardez le reportage signé
mickaël miro est pas très grec de
dixmude
des coups droits des amorties des
matches à enjeu le 28e open de tennis
d'elancourt a tenu toutes ses promesses
organisé depuis le 9 avril dernier au
parc des sports guy boniface l'événement
a attiré plus de 370 tesla venus d'île
de france mais également du nord de la
france s'est un temps dans la première
catégorie à 2400 euros de lots donc par
exemple vainqueur messieurs gagne 700
euros voilà donc il ya quand même un
enjeu financier d'argent à gagner les
finales étaient programmées ce samedi
chez les dames candice paillat de noisy
le roi s'est incliné contre elodie
buisson de blois après un match accroché
le score 4-6 7-6 6-4
elle a très bien joué sur les balles de
match et je me suis tendu de ce que
comme j'ai vu que je finissais pas je me
suis étendu dans les moments tendus et
ben je vais plus court déjà laissé plus
vrai que ce match est donc après alain
profiter et c'est vrai qu'elle a quatre
balles de match après gelé les jours
jeux les jouets bon j'ai un petit peu de
chance la chance mon côté après c'est
vrai que le match peut très bien être en
sa faveur et elle mérite au tout autant
que moi donc là dessus là dessus voilà
c'est je m'en sors mais je m'en sors ans
en allant un peu au culot comme on dit
chez les hommes rudy coco originaire de
bol favori du tournoi a remporté
l'épreuve pour la troisième année
consécutive le tennisman s'est imposé en
deux sets 6-1 7-6 contre éric forbach du
tc plaisir c'est la fin de cette édition
reste avec nous tout de suite vous
retrouver michael et demi d'euros pour
le ca du sport et tous les résultats
sportifs du week-end quant à moi je vous
retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition du journal je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée